[Music]
hey kids so we didn't we're not gonna be
able to fat man beyond this week
obviously I'm not at the cantina I'm at
my house so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna move over this side so I can see
the questions and we'll Q&A for a little
bit cuz it's Friday night a lot like
that matters it's night know days of the
week seem to matter anymore one just
rolls into the next so we're gonna kick
back here man and I'll answer some
questions for like a half an hour and
then we'll get back to our Friday nights
just a heads up on 4/20 I'm doing a
Mallrats watch along for the good folks
at focus Universal Universal has that
movie so on 4/20 man don't forget to
tune in mark your calendars ladies and
gentlemen an opportune memorable date
and we'll watch Mallrats together okay
let's dive into some Q&A shall we let's
check this out man where they're going
fast just had an earthquake 4.6 outside
Arizona yes down in Palm Springs
apparently they had an earthquake as
well so there's a chance we might feel
aftershocks here so if you see some or
you hear some rumbling or you know you
hear you might see me react man let me
tell you something
buggin there was a one time I felt an
earthquake here in California I've only
felt them like I think twice the first
time I did the windows in the house
buckled one of them and you could hear
him it was [ __ ] up so and I remember
being [ __ ] pissed scared so if that
happens if we do get a aftershock you're
gonna watch me be like oh god
Oh God ELLs like your dad make it stop
like I'm terrified of natural disasters
terrified of unnatural disasters
just generally scared in life all right
let's see how do you think the theater
industry will recover when this is all
over somebody asks I came they're going
so [ __ ] fast I can't I can't tell you
who's asked that question uh what's
gonna happen in theater industry I don't
know seems like it's gonna be a minute
before a bunch of people want to gather
in public together and it's gonna take
an awfully tasty cheese to get us mice
to head back outside so you know I mean
you know a Marvel movie would probably
[ __ ] do it
they got open strong when it comes back
you know theatrical distribution has
been changing for quite some time
exhibition is tougher and tougher for
lots of movies that aren't big event
movies and stuff so I don't know I'm
like we toured reboot right before all
this happen and stuff and that was my
new favorite model where I'm like oh I
can just take a movie out and for a
wallet and stuff like that and be there
for every public exhibition of the flick
but you know I once again I like we were
coming off the tour ever seen thousand
of 1,500 people a night I don't think
we'll ever be able to put that many
people in a room again for quite some
time I don't know if people will feel
comfortable amassing in a room like that
for quite some time so I'm not quite
sure what's gonna happen I don't think
it's gonna go away if that's what you're
asking like do I think the actual
distribution is dead absolutely not but
you know it's gonna be a while before
anything gets back to anything
resembling normal and I don't even know
if we necessarily will might be a new
paradigm which isn't necessarily
frightening remember George Carlin
talked about you know plastic
recyclables and he was just like you
know maybe
the earth wanted plastic for itself
couldn't invent it that's why him you
know we exist and and if it turns out he
said that the you know earth can't
ingest or break down plastic over
millions of years well then it'll just
create a new paradigm the earth plus
plastic is what he said we're gonna
enter a new paradigm that's for damn
sure folks the it's it's not going to go
back to what we all remember is normal
sounds like we're all gonna be wearing
masks all the time and stuff so you know
they're new fashion statements coming
kids now another place to wear your
message not just your your chest on a
t-shirt and stuff but you can also now
you know wear it on your mask believe me
I'll be [ __ ] wearing Jay and Silent
Bob [ __ ] branded masks for sure man
but you know if masks become a regular
way of life that would be you know
something in terms of like I'd be able
to tell [ __ ] kids that weren't
interested when I was young we didn't
have masks and be like okay boomer and
I'd be like I'm not [ __ ] boomer Oh
Jen X and they'll be like [ __ ] off Gen X
that's the next version of okay boomer
perhaps but yeah my life's gonna look
different but well whether this life in
the time of the plague alright let's see
what we got here
your boy Walt says he's been drawing a
lot what are they carrot what are the
what are the chances it's for my book
not for the Batman book not yet we
haven't talked about that so but that's
a good idea
I had a big conversation with Walt the
other day Walt Flanagan for those who
don't follow come on how could
without Walt I wouldn't be here Walter
of course a lot of people know if you
can comic book men luck a lot of people
know and love him from tell him Steve
Dave tez D Paul the ants and whatnot but
the other day I called wall and we were
talking about you know like everything
shut down of course including the stache
and so in the interim like you know
comic-book industries hasn't been on
very sturdy legs for the last few years
but you know with diamond distribution
being cut off the stores can't even get
books to you know give to reservist sell
to reservists
bare minimums in order to pay their
rents and whatnot and so it's gonna be
tough in the new economy which seems
like we're headed for depression for
many comic book stores to survive
through this it seems like so I you know
we're also a comic book store J and saw
Bob secret stash and I had to have a
serious heart-to-heart with Walter who's
you know run the store since we opened
it back in 1997 the nineties kids when
things were just better at least for me
so I thought I had in by Walters dry
well I I bought the store and the
contents of the store and we renamed it
Jay and Silent Bob's secret stash but it
was all for Walt
because Walt loved comic books at one
time we're driving around New Jersey
going to like comic book stores and
small conventions and stuff and we were
driving home and Walt was just like we
were having this conversation about love
and comic books like oh what a great day
I mean just driving around getting comic
books and stuff going to shows I said
Walter Ghost that's my dream job man if
I could have a dream job he said I would
love to run a comic book store and I
said yeah I'd be awesome owning a comic
book store and he goes no running a
comic book store
he goes owning is too much
responsibility as well around a complex
store it would get like 50% off my books
and [ __ ] could go out hunting for stuff
and you know Walter never asked for much
and he wasn't added and asking me for
anything because I we both broke as a
joke
but years later when I've made a movie
and suddenly had a job and I could
afford things and whatnot and the comic
book store that we used to shop at
became available
Steve Dave the guy that ran it he was
going to Taiwan Thailand one of the Thai
countries with his wife and he was gonna
shut the story goes all right I knew you
always talked about 102 comic book store
I said yeah one day I figured I would
that's how I you know they told me how
the movie business and I run a comic
store until I died he goes well this
one's available and I said really
and he goes $60,000 and I was like wow
60 grand and he goes you know what 30
and like instantly he was bidding
against himself and I was like 30 grand
that was only three grand more than it
costs to make clerks
and clerks was all my dreams coming true
so I reached out to to Walt and said hey
I got comic ology that's the story was
called kamikaze I took over comm ecology
man we're gonna rename at Jay and Silent
Bob's secret stash and you were gonna
run it and he was like no nut I was like
what he talked about and he didn't want
to do that he liked his job at the
recreation center so he didn't want to
leave it so he helped Brian Johnson also
from comic book men also from tezi run
it for the first like two years like you
know it was like Cyrano de Bergerac
affair Brian was the front man Christian
and [ __ ] Walter was Cyrano order in
the books and you know tell him brought
what to do but I didn't necessarily know
the world comics Walter did tip Walt's
in two years before he committed a
full-time and left the High Line's
Recreation Center and came to run the
secret stash full
so at that point you know dream come
true at least for me to give Walter his
dream or what he said it was a dream
once in a car while we were driving
around New [ __ ] Jersey I tend to take
things very seriously so you know the
store I was talking about the other day
and I was just like well the store
exists because you loved comics and now
you don't really collect comics you you
he collects the Marvel master works he
only collects old versions or bound
versions of the books that he absolutely
loves so you know I was like as goes
your interest in comics so goes the
comic book store and you know we're
gonna be closed for a while and a lot of
stores are gonna be closing in this
economy and and you know we've been in
business for over like 20 years so like
you know we had a good run like I said
you're the boots on the ground Walt
like you know what the day-to-day on the
store is what do you think
should we think about closing Jay and
Silent Bob's secret stash and I was so
surprised that Walter was like no I
wouldn't do that cause it really and he
goes well he's gone you know you say
like the stash was for me he's going
maybe that's how it started but it's not
what it became because it's now its own
living organism people come from all
over to see the place you know that and
it means something to a lot of people
not just people in town the people would
do teste but like people who travel to
see it and you know I was like yeah but
like is anybody gonna be traveling they
didn't even have money to go to a comic
book store once this is all over and if
they do it you know aren't they just
gonna order books online and maybe it's
done and and what was like wow he's gone
if I'm you like how I write out my lease
you got at least to the end of the year
he's gone when the store comes back see
how it's going and stuff and if it's not
going well then think about maybe ending
it but not now he was like you know I
never
when I left the other day and locked the
door I never thought I wouldn't return
like for business and you know waltz
like an old sitcom fan and he's this
like jorssy to see the series finale of
Mary Tyler Moore Show
I said yeah he's like I said where
they're all hugging he said yeah but I
thought that would be me I thought I
would turn the lights off on the stache
and that would be the end of the stache
he's gone like I didn't get that moment
so you know I was like look man I
honestly I'm surprised I thought you'd
be like he looks well it's not the most
nostalgic guy I thought you'd be like
[ __ ] let it let it go man time to let
it go but Walt was like no hold on it so
I said to him I said Walt like you know
as a guy who's been my friend for 30
years or more I said one of the things I
love about you best is your ability to
still surprise me even this late in the
game so stash is is there and we're
gonna try to weather this and whatnot
you know it'd be nice to be there when
the dust clears if we can you know
afford it and thanks to you know my day
job we might be able to hang in there
for a little longer than most I feel bad
for other stores man um you know it's
I'd know what they're facing and at
least I have the luxury of being like
well let's soldier on a little bit even
if it's a pinch some people don't even
get that luxury okay
hey keV I was in the Richmond reboot
Roadshow of that this last February my
question is thank you for going kam my
question god dammit these things they go
my question is what was the gift bag the
ten-year-old gave you I left after you
picked him for the final Q&A question
cocaine
ten-year-old gave me a big bag of
[ __ ] Richman's purest China white man
who's crazy
this a big bag of coke from a child you
know they run hard in Virginia you know
they say Virginia is for lovers but for
hard drugs as well and I as a STONER I
didn't know what to do with all that
cocaine so we sold it you know as we
kept heading down on tour made a little
sad scratch you know god bless that
little kid III know he didn't give me
cocaine nobody ever gives me cocaine we
need is my cocaine ladies and gentlemen
I'm not saying this is weed this is for
all you know just a rolled cigarette
it's not know what the rules are in this
place but uh yeah man I let me see what
was in the bag I don't I don't recall if
it's I mean like I got here I got this
petrow fee violet verse gave me blood
award that says violet versus award of
excellence for the best reboot remake
and sequel she's a little kid little
girl who gave me that award so if that's
what you're talking about that was there
and also clock the shape like a heart
and it said I have big heart love to do
that really really sweet
okay let me see what's crackin keV not
much Chris have you ever considered
making a murder mystery type movie with
your characters it would be amazing I
I'm sure that a creative person could do
just that with my very own IP or the
characters I've created I'm not that guy
I I you know if I was gonna make a
murder mystery it wouldn't be with my
characters i am ryan johnson man i can't
i ain't got a knives out hanging up
around here and stuff like that i ain't
that clever or talented or attractive i
donno if you've ever seen ryan johnson
person he sat in this [ __ ] very
across from me and [ __ ] I looked at that
guy I was like he's a brick and I'm
drowning slowly he's telling some kid in
any event I don't have a murder mystery
in my head but I can recommend some
Murder by Death
funny funny movie from my childhood you
know some people of course love clue I
what would i I'd like to do a courtroom
drama one day if life is long enough not
with my characters but I'm you know I'm
a big [ __ ] Law & Order guy and
particularly the second half of the show
I love him that I go to trial you know
why think about trial just people
[ __ ] talking you ain't got to know
action man you throwing one guys like
I'll get ya and then that [ __ ] cops
drag him down or something like that so
uh yeah I'd love to do courtroom [ __ ]
drama my farts talking at each other oh
my god that's what I do it's like a
podcast come to life with stakes but not
these kind of stakes man like [ __ ]
legal stakes so yeah no knives out for
me I'm a love the move I can't make
something like a knives out man but one
day maybe I'll make like a [ __ ] 12
Angry Men but not as good but just like
you know 12 Angry Men due to like guilty
just because they won't get to lunch all
right man let's let's see Karl Cox's hey
keV you should make a new movie about
Jay and Sam Bob saving the stache shop
if you were to take on that project how
would you start the movie up the
original version of Jay and Silent Bob
strike back saw Jane saw Bob not going
cross-country to stop a movie from
happening but instead like a quick stop
what was it was closing and Dante and
Randall like we're over the moon
ecstatic about it and Jay and Sanne Bob
were like we'll have no place to hang
out so it was about them trying to stop
the destruction of quick stop and to do
that they went on this quest one of the
places they were gonna go was to Newark
New Jersey where they were shooting a
movie Good Will Hunting - hunting season
and so you know
and then it changed it became like
watches haven't go to [ __ ] Hollywood
dumbass and I was like oh of course
and so that element of it went away but
maybe one day maybe that's what Jane saw
Bob three would be a bounce we did Jay
and Silent Bob strike back and we'll we
did Jay and Silent Bob reboot as well
and we figure in 15 years if we're ever
going to do this again we do one more
time hopefully we're both alive
hopefully we haven't all succumb to to
the pandemic hopefully we're not living
holes underground and [ __ ] [ __ ]
twelve monkey-style hiding from the army
of the twelve Monkeys then hopefully
we'll get to a third Jane solid Bob
movie where you know how Harley my
daughter was in Jay and Silent Bob
strike back to play baby Sam above and
then years later eighteen years later
she blade Millie the third lead and Jay
and Silent Bob reboot so Jays daughter
Logan was in Jay and Silent Bob reboot
she played Holden's daughter spoilers if
you haven't seen yet and so we figured
fifteen years like she just turned a
five years old yesterday April 1st so in
15 years she'll be 20 so she'll be old
enough to be the third lead in the movie
that Jane saw Bob 3 Harley will play her
mother and this time Jane saw Bob have
to stop yet another iteration probably
of Bluntman and chronic and stuff and so
at that point maybe will or maybe it's
they've got to save the quick stop and
if I had hold on to it for 15 more
[ __ ] years then it's them trying to
save the [ __ ] quick stuff and they
have to go back to Hollywood to stop a
[ __ ] movie from doing all over again
and Jays daughter gets to you know we
get to act with Jays grown up Dartmouth
that'd be fun if we have any mind left
you know if dementia hasn't come in and
[ __ ] just taking me in Jay okay let's
see T Steven says hey Kevin how has your
writing style changed over the years
love all your flicks especially clerks -
thank you I love clerks too as well
how's my writing style changed over the
years you know I honestly was able to
embrace kind of my softer side as time
went on in the beginning I was more like
hey man I'm [ __ ] I'm just above it
man I'm just that's all you and we're
just over here gen-x watch and then
commenting and [ __ ] and then I realized
you know that it's much easier for me to
just wear my [ __ ] heart on my sleeve
so that's how you get to like chasing
Amy and stuff like that and Jersey girl
tusks even tusks is like even though
it's a weird fucked-up movie there's
this like beating heart in that movie
Jane saw Bob reboot and stuff so it's
you know it's I guess I've gotten softer
that's what anybody wants to hear again
I used to be [ __ ] hard what happened
other guy that made clerks man even
kidding [ __ ] [ __ ] I was like well he
was always a [ __ ] now he just became
more comfortable with [ __ ] showing it
and then people are go okay boomer I'm
like I'm not a [ __ ] boomer man
my parents were boomers I am Gen X if
I'm anything yeah so so the writing has
changed in as much as I've been able to
let go of like hey man I can't [ __ ]
show how I feel now that's all I do now
if I can go on here and cry while
watching the [ __ ] so you know young keV
Smith he wouldn't have stood for that
he'd have been trying to be cool and
[ __ ] I've we found a big [ __ ] tub of
videos VHS is and dr. Josh Roush
who was with me and then live on the
reboot Roadshow tour but he does the
mixin and scratching for Hollywood
babble-on all the time he gave him all
the VHS and he's been
converting [ __ ] from VHS to like digital
and it's a [ __ ] [ __ ] ton of news
pieces from like when I first got in the
business or like when we were making
chasing amy and there was this piece
like I saw today this MTV news piece
about chasing amy it was just about to
open in New York LA Boston Chicago like
like top-10 markets or something and
Kurt Loder remember Kurt Loder was so
dismissive and shitty during intro of
this news piece he was just like you
know Smith had a minor hit with clerks
and then a massive flop with Mallrats
and and then he was like talking about
chasing amy is the story of this and he
goes but the big question is you know
will anyone care I don't think that dude
ever like me man I think I don't think
he was impressed by my clerks [ __ ]
so in any event yeah I saw a bunch of
old videos man and we're gonna be
putting them up soon I think on the
Internet to share with people or
interested in the [ __ ] right but I've
seen a lot of video of young Kevin Smith
and I hate young Kevin Smith you know
some people always say young Kevin Smith
some people hate President Kevin Smith
that Kevin's man uh yeah I I watch
whenever I watch yeah young Kevin Smith
getting interviewed him always like oh
would you smile you dick like you made
clerks [ __ ] look like [ __ ] in
soutien you are how like [ __ ] like
like eases deliveries all down here he
doesn't know how to present himself
publicly some people like that version
though some people I go wish that guy
like that's when I put up pictures of me
on Instagram and I'm like like smiling I
got my eyes widen [ __ ]
I do that cuz I was tired of looking at
pictures of me looking like this so I
was like I'll just do this do something
rather than do nothing and so a most
catchy [ __ ] on instagram pic boy stop
[ __ ] open your eyes all wide stop it
oh my god
fair enough you're rock that's what's
wrong in this world I'll [ __ ] let my
eyes closed a little bit now
everything's better
let's see
Michael Underwood says being the
guardian of pop culture took me know
about that some people would say the
record pop culture would you consider oh
[ __ ] where'd that go
would you consider creating a ready
player one miniseries based on the book
and expanded correctly oh you didn't
like the Spielberg movie um no I
couldn't do better than that
oh my god [ __ ] if you didn't like it
is you really wouldn't like mine but
always like that that I got reference to
the book or any reference being that
book man I always thought that was that
was really sweet particularly of the
company he referenced me and was very
very nice but to pay him back I would
not be the guy that you want to adapt
that that takes vision on that vision um
let's see Kevin do you play any video
games as d are you kidding me - I play
video games
not really I used to but only scroll a
side-scrolling games I was never this
guy never first-person shooter and stuff
that's Jason he does that um and it's
not because I'm against it it's just cuz
I was busy making stuff it's tough to
make stuff and pursue hobbies at the
same time and I I know some people are
like you're [ __ ] rich I'm not I'm
really really really not I live
hand-to-mouth like most people it's just
my hands are bigger in the mouths of
many around me so but yeah so I'm uh I'm
not quite a gig worker but like I don't
I'm not Scrooge McDuck we had sitting on
[ __ ] the mountain well that's why I
work so much that's why I see so much of
me all over the place cuz I'm shucking
and jiving and trying to make a living
and stuff like that ah did that answer
the question I didn't forget what the
question was but Guardian of pop culture
oh yeah so no you don't want yeah you
know I can't pull off ready player one
uh-oh that was the other question I
forget which question I was answering um
let's see after the crown of madness is
over says superg
g-money oh not after it's over quartz
three gets made will you tore it like
reboot and bring the tour to Manchester
UK Manchester England and and [ __ ] yeah
man if we get to make clerks three I'll
pay for that [ __ ] myself and I'm at work
for a year man i goddamn year although
now it's scary to like think about
because if this pandemic it broke out
before our reboot tore open and kicked
off we'd have been [ __ ] man
so thankfully the tour ended just as you
know people who were like get inside and
then and the pandemic started so I don't
know if we'll ever be so lucky as to be
able to travel around like we just did
with that movie and enjoy packed
theaters and stuff for quite some time
because I think people will be reticent
to gather in large numbers for a while
if we're even allowed to I mean I read
an article today that talked about how
there may be intermittent social
distancing like for the next two years
until there is you know a vaccine which
means like we may be inside for like a
month
and then they're like you can go outside
again and then get back inside for
another month or something like that so
rolling rolling
lockdowns or whatever so if that's the
case who knows but if I can I would
finance clerks three and tore that [ __ ]
myself for a year straight cuz we tore
it reboot for four months and I had a
blast it was amazing and I could have
kept going I mean we couldn't have kept
going because everything changed but if
nothing had changed and movie hadn't
come out on video I just wouldn't keep
going so clerks three I fully intend to
tour and we will take Adam and Chester
that's for damn sure
all right let's see man Led Zeppelin
rules 21 says hey Kevin what directors
influenced you and any advice for
understanding cinematography Led
Zeppelin you're gonna ask me to
understand summat ography all
we've ever seen any anti flip but like
[ __ ] nobody's ever accused me of
knowing what I to do with a goddamn
camera but I have been influenced by
many that's me hitting my nose I had
nothing to blow but you're not allowed
[ __ ] even hit your nose anymore so
many yells yeah somebody and by somebody
I mean my [ __ ] kid um the who are the
filmmakers that influenced me as easy
how Richard Linklater slacker was the
first movie I saw that made me think oh
my god maybe I could be a filmmaker
which is weird because Richard Linklater
is an amazing filmmaker and I'm not but
you know just because you're not great
at something doesn't mean you can't
[ __ ] engage with it and try it you
know what I'm saying like some people
are born talented some people are born
to make movies you know Martin Scorsese
Quentin Tarantino just to name a couple
but just because you're not talented
like those cats don't mean like you
shouldn't [ __ ] try like you know look
not everyone's Wayne Gretzky or Mario
Lemieux some people just enjoy playing
hockey because it's [ __ ] fun right so
you know the same thing so I love
Richard Linklater because I saw slacker
said that make that that counts as a
movie I want to be a movie maker I think
I could do it too how Hartley was no
filmmaker I absolutely adored that put
me on the path for his stuff put me on
the Pettine and put me on the path
himself his his work trust the movie I
loved with Adrian Shelly Martin Donnelly
he put that he put that movie out he's
big hero of mine and then one day in the
New York Times Magazine section I think
it was they were talking about they're
doing a how heartily piece and he was
overseas somewhere I think it was
Germany or something like that and he
was doing a Q&A and you know I dedicated
clerks at the end of clerks to the for
filmmakers Richard Linklater how Hartley
Jim Jarmusch
and Spike Lee Richard Linklater how
Hartley ginger a spike Lee and I said
thank you for leading the way Matt my
way um Illeana Douglas when she was
dating Martin Scorsese
they watched clerks together and she
told me that when he watched that one
Chris Hayes II was like oh they led the
way that always made me laugh
so in any event now name-dropping and
forgetting why the [ __ ] I was talking
about
oh how Hartley was at this this in the
article in The New York Times article in
magazine section article they talked
about like somebody had brought up in a
queue a hey the guy who made corks he
cites you it was an influence how do you
feel about that in the description said
that how hartley gave an answer response
so vitriolic that he had to go lay down
afterwards I was like that was my idol
so I don't think he cared for clerks
very much I'm so richard linklater how
hartley jim jarmusch without jim
jarmusch without seeing a stranger than
paradise without seeing down by law
stranger yeah i I wouldn't have had a
look for clerks he won't talk about
cinematography I had no idea how to
compose but I love Jim Jarmusch's stuff
because he just turned the camera on
less [ __ ] happen in front of that kind
of maison scene style so that's what I
leaned toward the look of Jim Jarmusch's
stuff I mean clerks looks like down by
law or not as you know well done and
that's not because the Dave Klein is a
genius DP a boy Dave Klein is shot
clerks Mallrats
chasing amy shot clerks to Zack Mary
even he was on True Blood for a while
then he's been on a homeland for like a
decade or whatever he was just shooting
a season 2 episode of Mandalorians son
that's right that's right
with Robert Rodriguez son that's what I
read on the Internet's so uh let me see
and then of course Spike Lee
I love Spike Lee and Spike Lee's books
were insanely influential for what I
wound up doing
I mean clerks you know takes liberally
from do the right thing
it happens all in the span of one day in
one block it just doesn't have anything
important to say clerks like like do the
right thing good and stuff but yeah
Spike Lee it was another one without
whom I wouldn't be doing what I do right
now seeing his movies made it seem
possible and not because like I could do
the X I can't do if he did um I I was at
Dogma over at kin in 1999 with Dogma and
Spike Lee and his wife were sitting
behind me watching the movie and they
liked it vocally out loud didn't like it
yeah my idols the people that I
generally am like I love those kids I'm
not all of them but how Hartley and
Spike Lee were both just like you know
I'm glad you like my [ __ ] kid but [ __ ]
off you don't get my [ __ ] or whatever no
in a nice way they would ever mean to me
or anything like that
um Jarmusch I never met so I don't know
how he felt about all my [ __ ] but
Richard seemed very flattered and he was
just in a documentary about me that was
going to be playing at South by
Southwest my friend Malcolm
Ingram's documentary called clerk so
that was kind of sweet and thrilling for
me he wasn't in the dock going like I'm
gonna say some [ __ ] so harsh about Kevin
Smith I need to lay down at work it's
but those are the four filmmakers that I
crediting clerks and they're definitely
in my creative DNA still to this day
hopefully somewhere along the road I've
done them proud to the point where like
well alright at least you did that
okay badger is that badger one what a
great name badger one I'm trying to get
to your question red state was one of
your finest ever [ __ ] you ain't
kidding son Kevin can I ask you about
your vegan what a bait-and-switch can I
ask you about your vegan change please
is it sticking do you find yourself
sliding back at all into old habits
first off I agree with you about rest
say oh my finest hour if I took my name
off red state you never woulda known
that I'm a red state man you've been
like a good filmmaker made this [ __ ]
[ __ ] Kevin Smith should watch his [ __ ]
learn how to make a good [ __ ] movie
veganism has been honestly very easy for
me I've been a vegan now I became vegan
like I you know the day after more exact
which was February 26 2018 so I've been
a vegan for over two years
and it's not been difficult for me at
all I don't crave any of the stuff that
I used to eat
I'm not militant about it for others
where I'm like you got a [ __ ] go
vegan although I'm a I'm not saying
nothing but like maybe we should all
stop eating animals but whatever [ __ ]
you know I I don't want to buy it
veganism works for me out of heart
attack so I wouldn't be getting stuff
used to be happy now I'm vegan but it's
been very easy for me and it saves my
life on a regular basis because I got
too much cholesterol in my system anyway
and stuff that's why I had the harder
heart attack so uh yeah veganism
absolutely works me hadn't back slid I'm
sure there have been moments where I was
ingesting some sort of like [ __ ]
closed meat thing or whatever a cloak
was animal product I mean while we were
on the reboot road trip to her I was
stopping at Burger King to get
impossible whoppers or stopping at
Carl's jr. or what do they call it
elsewhere Hardee's to get beyond burger
and you know I'm sure they're not like
we cook this way the [ __ ] away from the
meat products and stuff like that so I'm
not like militant where I look at the I
will look at the label and [ __ ] but like
you know like my there's some [ __ ] my
kid won't even eat cuz she's like that's
they use a bone filter made from animal
bone something like Jesus so I am a
simple vegan I hate vegetables very much
my family ordered some food from my
vegan gold last night restaurant out
here and it was like I looked at all
like this all vegetables feel like it's
from a vegan joint as a Cabot why can't
they make this vegetable look like a
[ __ ] hamburger like veggie grill
so I and I'm a dirty vegan is what I'm
saying
it's not like whoo I just had me a side
of spinach like no they gotta make it
look like something else or but I'm all
plant-based hundred percent man and I do
love beyond burgers so it's not like I
miss out on hate more beyond burgers
than I ever ate of hamburgers my entire
life so yeah if the Eagan ism is um it
works for me I don't [ __ ] force it
down anybody else's throat but for me
[ __ ] whenever people like you lost a lot
of weight he looked [ __ ] good and
like it's veganism like you know I hate
sick because I know books some people
but it's that simple so uh it works very
well for me but you know again I didn't
choose it cuz I was like me you know I
feel like a change I had to [ __ ] do
something
my kid was like you're gonna die can you
will you try veganism cuz she's been a
vegan for three years before me and she
loved me and so naturally she wanted to
save my life but I know my kid she's
[ __ ] strategic she was also like if I
could flip this [ __ ] he's a huge
gift for the vegan community he's got
big mouths and he'll be out there
[ __ ] saying vegan vegan vegan so she
was right
but yeah so I vegan plant-based but I'm
not
I don't eat clean I'm dirty being a
[ __ ] filthy vegan speaking of food
man maybe this is a good time to
announce it sure for again we're going
to be doing this this pop-up restaurant
in Los Angeles when you know [ __ ] the
world goes back to normal with the folks
that did like the Saved by the Bell
pop-up and they did the Breaking Bad
pop-up saved by two max I think one was
called so they do these themed
restaurants and so they asked Amy if you
want to do movies I was like [ __ ] yeah
so we're gonna be doing like a movies
pop-up like when you know hopefully in
the summer when everything hopefully if
we get out in the summer again where you
can actually go and sit down in a movies
and stuff but we're gonna like do this
thing coming up we're gonna pre do it
like here in Los Angeles
you're gonna be able to post mates
movies this month which will be fun and
proceeds going to charity so I'll let
you know more about that in the future
but it's gonna be really [ __ ] fun I
always dreamed about you know I've
stupid little dreams and that's
important kids those stupid little
dreams because it's tough to make the
big ones come true dream little and
they're achievable oh [ __ ] and so I had
a stupid little dream forever about
having a [ __ ] restaurant like where
we could serve a sandwich called the Jay
and Silent Bob [ __ ] smoker like a
chicken sandwich but you know we're we
did we did that once up at the Lovitz
club when we were doing podcasts up at
City Walk how the Jon Lovitz theater
podcast theater but you know we I got to
put the joke and Jay and Silent Bob
reboot but I think we're gonna have that
on the menu along with cow tippers and
stuff like that at the pop-up movies
which will you know it'd only be for a
couple months then go away or something
like that but it's me [ __ ] fun man
watch my Instagram and Twitter for
details coming up and very [ __ ] soon
and the food selection is it's funny um
okay let's let's go go into here
kevin says judy dooby doo
he says dooby dooby doo if you could
wield any lightsaber of your choosing
whose would it be and what color would
be give me the dark save her son that's
right we've seen everyone's got those
[ __ ] lightsabers give me the dark
saber man that we saw at the end of the
Mandalorian Giancarlo Esposito will than
that [ __ ]
Zachary Nathan says Kevin a chance to
work with criterion collection again to
give Clark stop I'm not chasing Amy give
them the criterion a treatment uh I
don't know I mean I like I guess I
wonder if we could do reboot with with
the good folks at criterion um if Susan
arrastia if she's still there we worked
with her on the chasing any laserdisc
criterion laserdisc years ago
and there's some like criterion like
purists who are like chasing a me is a
blight on the criterion collection and
stuff I don't feel that way and I was a
big collector of criterion laserdiscs
back in the day so I've been with the
company you know going way the [ __ ] back
so I you know maybe that it's not it's
not like you know they're like we don't
want you we want you we don't want
they're not as you know club' as they
seem a lot of people just can't do stuff
with them because like there was a time
when we did the chasing amy laserdisc
you know DVD was still coming and once
DVD happened then every home you know
every every studio every distributor
they were like oh [ __ ] we can make DVDs
we don't have to we don't have to
[ __ ] like let them do it what you do
special edition things and they start
keeping their stuff more in-house so I
you know I mean I guess I got we got
tons of material and be sure to reach
out to Susan air staking and be like
Susan can we do reboot and she's like
bro you're lucky chasing amy got through
the door man but it'd be nice I should
reach out and see it might have just
given me an idea okay what about moose
jaw's updates as Jill Barlow moose
Charles the movie I'm doing that's jaws
but with a moose instead of a shark that
is weird it's so weird that you bring it
up we have a phone call about it with
some of the folks that we made reboot
with next week a conference call so uh
yeah it may be bubbling back to life man
would not be nice head up to the
Canadian outdoors spread far apart from
everybody making movies man one day when
we're allowed to do that sort of thing
again so yeah movement on moose jaw's
okay let's see what about Kilroy Was
here says Andrew Galvin it's all cut man
it's I've seen it cut together
and we were going to go out with it to
this one place for this meeting but then
all this stuff happened so it'll wait
until this stuff passes but then yeah
we're taking it into this place man it's
it's it's fun it's really really good it
turned into something like it reminds me
a Creepshow not nearly as good as
Creepshow but that's kind of what we
were doing anthology like that little
horror anthology rubber mask our
anthology so it turned out wonderful
okay Jeremiah who was a bullfrog asked
how are you in the family holding up
good pretty much Harley's the stickler
in the house who's like you've got to do
this they said to do this although I saw
her walking today without a mask and I
was like oh you got to do this cuz they
yesterday they said we gotta start
wearing masks just but every time we go
out so but she's the one that's like
leave your shoes to the door
we've cleaned off every single thing
that we bought at the food store with
[ __ ] Clorox wipes and stuff before we
bring it into the house Byron and Gail
they're the ones were desperately trying
to protect in the house they're both
over 70 and whatnot Nana pop if you will
so they're holding up well and me and
Jenn have not killed each other yet you
know we don't we haven't really fought
or anything like that but you know we'd
to be fair what there's enough space
where like I got my own office and she's
down in the bedroom and stuff and
sometimes you know she can go to a
living room so we're not always in each
other's space but we also kind of you
know we've been together 20 years so
wanna have me we've been married 20
[ __ ] 21 years [ __ ] I mean not [ __ ]
21 like we've been [ __ ] for 21 years
but married for 20 years
we're coming up on oh [ __ ] the
anniversary is soon this month is Jenn's
birthday is April 7th
and then April 25th is our 21st wedding
anniversary so that means no [ __ ] as of
right now what are we in March yes
me and Jen have been [ __ ] for 22
years so yeah that's a long way of
saying I'm not bragging that's a long
way of saying we've been together we
know how to be around each other without
being like I [ __ ] hey yeah you know
and we just spaced out and stuff and we
do a lot of together alone [ __ ] which is
like you know she's over on the couch
I'm on the bed and we're both you know
watching separate programs but we're in
the same room together you know she got
a dog I got a dog
those dogs don't get along so we're
always kind of like in separate places
and stuff so yeah we haven't gotten any
real battles and stuff it's been okay I
mean I've said a bunch but like I just
came off the road so I'm okay to be in
the house for a while all right let's
see would you offer Zach pieces would
you offer your throat with your throat
to the wolf with the red roses
that sounds cryptic without from my
throat to the wolf with the red roses
that's is that that's is that a
homoerotic thing like all right you're
out off of my trope to the wolf with red
roses okay favorite MCU moment a space
tiger oh come on what a great question
and so damn many hmm alright you know
what
here it is I'm [ __ ] calling it man
I'm calling it and believe me it's tough
as you can see how tough it was I came
up with it just like that alright so you
know we all love the big moments of the
[ __ ] Thor picking up mole and ear you
know I am Iron Man stuff like that so
those are great and I'm not saying they
shouldn't be in the running of course
they're amazing but I think my favorite
Marvel moment
excuse me I got to take you back to the
first Ironman and I think it's the death
of yinsen ho that on the back of that
poor man is built the antenna get
emotional talking about this built the
entire Marvel Cinematic Universe as he
sacrifices himself so that Tony the guy
that he didn't really like could get out
of the cave Tony Stark is taught the
true meaning of heroism and when he says
don't waste your life's started oh this
still [ __ ] gets me you can see this
is why it's my favorite moment in all
the Marvel movies in that moment Ironman
is born you don't get to the snap unless
that happens that is that's right that's
what I was gonna say robbed on junior
that's Tony Stark paying back Henson all
those years later by giving his life by
being the person who lays down on the
wire and stuff so yeah I love that scene
so much and I love I love when he goes
thank you for saving my life best scene
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe amazing
second best sequence might be for me
Captain America the First Avenger Tommy
Lee Jones scene where he throws the
grenade on the ground and Steve you know
scrawny Steve Rogers dives on it and
everybody runs away and he's like go
he's holding on to it that's the stuff
that heroes are [ __ ] made of man yeah
oh [ __ ]
I mean I believe me I loved the big
flashy [ __ ] and I love I loved when wand
is like you took everything from me and
he's like I don't even know who you are
and she's like you will and then she
almost [ __ ] kills that [ __ ] almost
kills
that goddamn deviant and when I say
deviants I mean you know the eternal so
uh cuz that's what Dennis was but Titan
um the type the mad Titan he was a user
deviant so uh yeah man I love all those
wonderful [ __ ] moments but it's that
quiet stuff that's still roots but
that's why I stay with the I mean all
the movies they only get better as time
goes on each one seemingly surpassing
the last but you those move those
moments in those two movies that that's
what rooted me you know I love stories
of superhumans but it's the human part
of the superhuman that I'm most
interested in the super part is fun to
look at the whiz-bang but is telling a
compelling story about a human being who
makes choices that's what I love about
those movies off they're not any of that
alright let's see hey keV George says
your episode of movie fights was great
and Bernard anan movie trivia Schmo down
was to anything like this you do you'd
like to do would do again yeah and the
heartbeat I'm happy to do movie fights
again I'm happy to [ __ ] ass I got a
modown for the first time ever so yeah
I'm game believe me if I can you know I
love being around and stuff um you know
trying to [ __ ] stick my face in
everybody space people I'm relevant
[ __ ] remember me Clark's you
know so I'm if they want me to do it I'm
happy to do it let's see this one says
oh my god aneurism fun pun says why was
the airbag deployed it clerks to jail
bomber the airbag being deployed in real
life Jay got into a little wreck and an
airbag deployed but then he was driving
around with it for like days I'm cop
drove past and saw it [ __ ] blown out
his windows like what the [ __ ] and then
pulled him over and they got in trouble
for something else and stuff so yeah
that literally happened to Jay um let me
see Santa scrub burger says I'm not in
to the same stuff as you and gonna
transfer
from a community college to university
in the next two years what do you
recommend oh man I lost you
where'd you go what do you recommend I
do to even do a third of the cool things
you have done I guess you can't care
about anything important
you can't like strive to be the best
you can't like go you know I want to win
an Oscar or one day you know because if
you focus on just those things then you
don't get to do all the other kind of
[ __ ] around that's I don't know I'm like
a poodle
you know or Homer Simpson like oh that
man's an exact replica duplicate of me
uh-huh that dog is a puffy tail so like
I get interested in other things real
fast and so I'm like ooh let's try that
whoo let's try that so it's that
willingness to try everything be a
jack-of-all-trades but a master of none
that opens you up for that sort of thing
so if you're interested in that and
doing as much weird stupid [ __ ] as I've
done you just can't pursue excellence
ever hears God I take good enough in
everything good nice good enough move on
a [ __ ] then you cover a lot of [ __ ]
around let me see Jordan 1996 says
you're a true legend keV please come to
Australia when all this virus stuff
blows over so I can watch my first live
show stay black I will and we were gonna
be coming to Australia with reboot but
then bum bum bum a virus so when this is
all done hopefully we'll be heading down
in Australia that we were planning to be
there by the end of the year for a big
tour anyway so hopefully that can still
hold man okay let's see
Guillermo Rodriguez says Martha
Washington Frank Miller's best comic
would mark barnard agree I don't know if
Margo to gray I liked my the Washington
but I personally for me that doesn't
feel like Frank Miller's best comic the
Dark Knight
you know returns will always be for my
money Frank Miller's finest hour such a
great writing what an epic tale and you
know that art is amazing too but man
that writing ah gambler gamble mr. Smith
is my father I just wanted to let you
know that you're an inspiration watching
your films it was one of the best
formative experiences in my life man I
just wanted you to know that oh my god
how [ __ ] sweet are you thank you for
that man that means the world and I know
what that means I don't just say that
like oh I means the world moving on like
I there were people who were formative
for me and so I know what that means
thank you um let's see Jason Teeter says
what do you feel about online
commentators like red letter media and
other armchair critics have they
improved and heightened the discussion
of movies or made things worse I don't
think people commenting on movies could
make things worse I don't think they
have that kind of power and I'm not like
saying they're powerless but like
they're commenting on stuff that's
happening and if people think that all
the studios are like let's do what they
said that I've not seen that to be the
case I know like everyone feels that way
with rise of Skywalker's there's a lot
of fan [ __ ] service here and stuff
you know I think sometimes they listen
but most times I don't really think they
do they're going about their own thing
you know they can't plan for their world
and you know deal in hours in terms of
like people's reactions to it and stuff
like that so I you know I I don't
I think it's I think it's wonderful I
think everybody should [ __ ] jump
online and create a video talking about
what a movie means to them and stuff
personally I wouldn't waste time making
a video bash in the movie because
there's so many things to like I
wouldn't personally talk about [ __ ] I
didn't like I understand that's more fun
and people like to watch that more so
then it would just be up to me to be
more entertaining about telling you
something that I do like rather than you
know starkly entertaining by bashing
some [ __ ] I'm you know I've always liked
affectionately given noogies if you will
to some movies over the course of my
career and stuff like that so you can
love a thing and still like kind of make
fun of a thing but I
III don't think there's anything I don't
think I don't think people commenting on
movies on the Internet has necessarily
affected how movies are made in some
minor cases maybe in terms people were
like oh my god they don't like Sonic
what's the [ __ ] read ramen [ __ ] which
makes sense it's cartoon and they could
do that sort of thing why not use the
audience as a testing ground like the
Internet to be like let's see what they
think before you commit the rest of your
time and money and stuff and I'm glad
that people do that [ __ ] I mean look
sometimes people make videos with like
[ __ ] Kevin Smithee sucks and blah blah
blah
but whatever [ __ ] like I there are a lot
of videos where people like oh my god I
like Kevin Smith so I can't complain
that there are people that don't like my
[ __ ] unless I'm gonna complain that
there are people that do like my [ __ ] so
you know I'm all for it everybody like
should jump up and down and [ __ ] be
like this is my feeling my self
expression about someone else's self
expression and you don't have to be a
critic you know it's beat her like a
dyed-in-the-wool trained critic or
writing film criticism to like talk
about movies and what do you liked about
and we didn't like about and stuff like
that I'm in Christ this is one of the
few free things we get left to do in
this [ __ ] world man so I'm all for it
I hope everybody [ __ ] gets a
one day but do I feel like it's changed
moviemaking not not not really but not
and I'm not saying they're like no they
wasted their time I'm saying they've
it's done something better don't you get
it then like changing moviemaking for
the good or bad it's created an outlet
for self-expression for the audience as
opposed to like just dutifully sitting
there watching the thing and be like
thank you for your self-expression now
you can watch it and you can go home and
you make your self-expression and then
somebody watches that and then they
watch your video and they comment on
your video and so somebody's watching
their self-expression and it goes on and
on just like that [ __ ] hair
commercial shampoo commercial back in
the day so you know anything that
creates art begets art as they say so
yay I'm all for those things when you
gonna visit Muse on Twitch
Kevin said Andrew Markham soon you keeps
threatening to bring me on discord he's
like you got download this court and I
did and then he didn't follow through
and tell me when to like get on discord
with him and stuff so as soon as he does
I'm [ __ ] there man I know I'm doing a
twitch thing on April 7th at 8:00 in the
morning so maybe I'll do it from Jay's
channel all right let's see hey Kevin
Brandon says 8:00 Kevin do you think
we'll see the return of guila point soon
and see him solve his next mystery love
your flicks I don't know if we look we
wanted to make him moose jaw's them I
hope so you got to have deal the point
in the last [ __ ] of the guila point
trilogy so that would that back then we
talked about moose jaws is kind of
bubbling again so perhaps that's a good
enough obscure enough hey Kevin did the
nails join sliders I made you work hey
it's John face now how are you sir they
do I still have it then that lighter is
in my bedroom that's the letter that I
use in my bedroom
did you try yes I hope you remember me
of course I do and giving it to you at
the Charlotte reboot show and thanks for
the squid man shout out a few weeks ago
no worries John went to a couple of our
reboot road shows and and I still have a
a shaky Jersey for you John okay can we
please talk about hit somebody says ran
frisky I think Ram Persky yeah very soon
we're gonna be able to because there's
news but not right now
um let's see are you wearing pants says
Robert gamble [ __ ] no that's beauty of
this [ __ ] man it's [ __ ] barn door
style you know what's going on down
below let's see yeah for all you know
man
for all you know ain't nothing down
below just dick out son on a Friday
night just got paid got my dick out who
needs pants of course I'm wearing
[ __ ] pants dude you think I want my
dick out my little dick call out with
all this [ __ ] covin running around
and [ __ ] like that oh my god I'm wearing
[ __ ] three rubbers on top of my dick
so no kovat gets in there of course I'm
wearing pants we're all wearing pants
would you a kiss Sloan says would you
act in a Marvel or DC movie they asked
you to god yes god yes I want that way
more I look I don't want to direct one
of those movies people artists think
don't you want direct one of those
movies oh you should make a Marvel movie
I don't want to do that that looks hard
and time-consuming but I would love to
be in one of those Marvel movies are you
kidding me you see if they did kemal and
[ __ ] they turn you into a chiseled actor
man they give you one of them [ __ ]
those bodies of the chrises man like so
and and then also just everyone's like
everyone sees those movies the duck oh
my god you weren't [ __ ] a Marvel
movies stuff I mean they just referenced
Mallrats and had my name in it in
Captain Marvel and [ __ ] man like I was
hearing from people I had heard since
I've heard from since I was 5 years old
so I be amazing to be mmm
a movie [ __ ] yes but direct one I don't
have enough vision or talent for that
but I [ __ ] certainly be in one oh my
god that'd be fantastic all right let's
see man they're going so fast mo - MO -
says Paul Runyon [ __ ] yes mo - MO - here
let me see if I can go to you this is
something I brought with me to give to
Nina Eddie but I forgot so I'll give it
to her next time we record you're that
awesome
evylyn magnet how awesome is that man I
got that at the power come and put it on
your fridge so I got this to give to her
Marc got a Skeletor one but I forgot to
give it to her but man she crushed it
what a great job she i mean we're gonna
record with her again I just saw the
animatics 4 1 & 2 powerhouse animation
doing a nominal [ __ ] job man
I got weeping but you saw me get weepy
just like talking him about Tony Stark
so I got weepy [ __ ] like watching
some of the shits
episodes woman - this it's gonna be
amazing kids but that's a long ways away
early 2021 fingers crossed
who's this king pranksta we got royalty
in the house love you Kevin
love you - I was so happy to meet you in
Albany and talked to you in front of the
audience like that Jason Mewes rap song
coming soon what's your favorite view
askew scenes you ever shot I can't
imagine there's a Jason Mewes rap song
coming very soon he would have mentioned
that I'm sure and then what was it the
what was my favorite view askew scene I
ever shot you know probably uh the
reboot one with Ben and me and Jason
that was just Jay and Silent Bob reboot
yeah that was pretty beautiful it was
you know we hadn't done that together in
a long time and you know we got in a
room 22 years after we were all in a
room making chasing amy together
and made a mini sequel like you know in
the middle of Jay and Silent Bob reboot
and the scene said a lot about you know
being a dad and that's what I am now and
stuff and and it said a lot about you
know friendship and and and having been
in the scene and we hadn't worked with
Ben in quite some time all that was just
beautiful man it turned into like you
know it was a scene that did not exist
until last week production thank you
Kevin McCarthy but it's made the movie
so I loved shooting it it was a
wonderful house my favorite bit of thing
all right man I you know I'm about to
it's like we've been doing this 68
minutes so maybe we stopped 69 let's see
and to go out on 69 James Edwards asked
how do you like the Harley Quinn
animated series on DC Universe so good
oh my god like how jealous was I when I
watch this show I'm like they're cursing
like that's [ __ ] why didn't I think
of that why didn't I walk into DC and be
like a cartoon we're mother [ __ ]
curse the thing that made me laugh was
the first time Batman shows up Joker
goes this [ __ ] guy oh my god is
hysterical the whole [ __ ] show is
wonderful man performances are great
lake Bella's as poison ivy because great
Kelly Coco as as as the main character
Harlequin very funny and what's his name
[ __ ] them our boy man Alan Tudyk is
doing a funny Joker and [ __ ] so yeah
it's this really good really well done
my god I've been enjoying the [ __ ] I
just started watching two days ago I was
like holy [ __ ]
so yeah it's is worth watch all right
that's 69 minutes man we've spent 69
minutes together ladies and gentlemen on
a Friday night now I'm gonna let you get
back to your lives man next week don't
forget we'll be doing fat man be on live
streaming from the cantina me and Mark
the Norton I think me and Ralph are
gonna be doing Hollywood babble-on this
weekend maybe on Sunday we might be
live-streaming that as well so you'd be
able to look at
old mental and [ __ ] dad jokes to each
other and 420 April 20th it's gonna be
the mall rats watch party man
online and stuff I think I'm typing
through that oh maybe there's an image I
don't know maybe you could see me
watching the movie watching you watch
the movie cooking at dirty cooking and
looking at you like yeah you watch that
[ __ ] you look at him lick those pretzel
juices off his hands and [ __ ]
there it is thank you for being here and
hanging out tonight don't forget folks
to wash your hands don't forget to be
kind to one another particularly wider
locked down with each other or try not
to be short of patience and whatnot try
to understand that everyone's going
through the same [ __ ] you're going
through and we'll see each other very
soon thanks for hanging out this Friday
night sure I want to stop streaming yeah
[ __ ] sure man